what is the screenwriting path to
failure I love that question oh good I
actually adore that question because I
think everybody has this idea failure
but nobody knows what it is right I'm
going to fail and it's going to I'm
going to go down in flames and you know
you're not the only failure in
screenwriting is a not writing I wrote a
script five years ago I'm running around
with this one script I haven't touched a
typewriter or computer since then for
any creative purposes that is
screenwriting failure not writing new
content not generating new content
harping on old content not getting notes
huge huge huge in the failure of things
if you are tunnel visioned and this is
how it has to be and anything short of
this as I saw it on the page arrives on
the screen then it will be my failure
you will fail in that because this is
while writing a solitaire this is a
highly collaborative industry so the
relative failure is not writing not
writing new material not getting notes
wanting to be perfect
there is no perfection in this industry
it is all about getting notes learning
from notes getting notes that you hate
figuring out what to do with them
because other people's our people are
going to have to buy in so the road to
failure is really being stunted stinted
stunted stunted well what is I sorry to
interrupt you what what is being too
perfect because I think a lot of people
that try to be too perfect they don't
realize it so what is that it's always
thinking that it can be better and you
know most work can be better but there
is a point of diminishing returns right
there is a point where you are just
switching around your wordsmithing and
you're really the returns are you
improve it by a percent by half a
percent that's not going to do it so
when is the work ready when is it strong
enough when do you believe anymore
Canole a lot of writers feel very very
confident writing but not confident at
all getting the work out there so at
some point you have to understand okay
this is what it is this is what I wanted
it to be I'm a big believer in feedback
so getting feedback from people that you
trust who have some experience and
knowledge in the industry be they
other working writers or consultants
like Michael Hague which I'm Grisanti
that you've talked to or script readers
that are known for being really hard on
the work when they say you know it it's
good get it out there
at some point you have to let go at some
point you have to say yeah I can futz
with it forever and you can I promise
you that you can and I've seen writers
do it and I've had fights with writers
who've done it who just would harp on
the same script you have to accept it
for the potential that it has you have
to question whether or not you've
realized that potential did you do what
you wanted to do with the script did you
write the story that you wanted to tell
is it being received in the manner that
you want it to be received so are people
getting it are they connecting with it
are they enthused by it
if the answers to that is yes then you
get it out there as much as rejection is
part of the job and it is part of the
job you are going to get rejected and so
you better grow it or develop a tougher
skin you will be rejected get it out
there the point is to get that yes and
you have to get through a lot of noes to
get that yes but you have to get the
world out of the work out there it does
no good for you on the Shelf it does no
good for you sitting on the computer
without anybody seeing it of course you
want to scrutinize that the work is up
to par right you want to make sure that
the work is strong and you're getting
the feedback that it's strong enough for
people that who don't have to be nice to
you and that's a really big thing so it
can't just be your friends who are
concerned about maintaining friendship
right who are going to be a little bit
more forgiving because they understand
your intention they know what you went
for you didn't quite get there but they
saw it enough but people who will
scrutinize your work and be the manding
of it are telling you it's good to get
it out there get it out there that's how
you build a career you don't build a
career with one script that you're
precious about you build a career
writing great script after great script
and getting people getting a fan base
that's excited about you that's excited
to read the next thing then knows the
next thing is coming and want to be the
first on the list to get it from you
you